All right, this review quiz is about precedence and associativity.
Over here on the left, I've written out a grammar for list,
and list selections in Python, which is kind of cool.
An expression can be a list of integers separated by commas.
You can have as many integers as you want, and let's imagine there is some other rule
where int goes to [1, 2, 3] and we have tokens for that.
You can take the length of the list, or if you're given a list,
you can select off all but the last element.
If you have the list [1, 2, 3], then you just get the list [1, 2].
Now I tell you as part of this problem that "len" associates to the "right" and it has low precedence,
and selecting off all but the last element associates to the left and has high precedence.
Just like we may have told you before that multiplication has high precedence,
and addition has lower precedence.
Then the input here is I want to compute the length of [1, 2, 3] with the last element selected off.
The last element selected off. And then down here, I've parenthesized that input two different ways.
What I want you to do is check the box that corresponds to what are parse 3 looks like.
If we were to put this associativity and precedence declaration into our parser with this grammar,
which one of these worlds would we end up in?